We're gonna be using this tiny little microphone.
I'm an ASMR girly, so I love watching these videos.
I got some donuts yesterday at Sidecar.
This is what we're working with.
We got six different flavors, so let's try.
These are all the flavors we're working with.
I don't remember a lot of them,
so let's just try them together.
This is our first donut. I think it's an old fashioned with nutmeg,
cinnamon and some buttermilk.
I've heard that these are really,
really good doughnuts. I love the texture of it and it's not too sweet,
so I give it an 8 out of 10.
Maple bacon one. Lucky picked this one,
so I'm gonna have the tiniest little sliver of it.
This seems really intimidating.
I don't know whether I would usually go for this,
but let's give it a try.
Hmm.
Surprisingly, that was so good.
I give that a nine out of 10.
There's something about this sweet and savory aspect of this
that I really like, which I didn't think I would.
My daughter requested the one with the sprinkles,
so I'm also gonna just have a tiny little bite of it.
I think this one is called confetti cake.
The texture of this looks a little bit different,
but let's give it a try.
Mmhm.
It was my least favorite one so far.
It tasted more like a cake than a donut.
I didn't like that. Didn't like the flavors of it.
I give That one, a two out of 10.
Next up we have the huckleberry donut.
I first got introduced to huckleberries
when I went to Montana about three years ago,
and they're so good. So I'm very excited for this one.
The flavor is really good.
I'm not a fan of the texture. Again,
it tastes more like a cake than a donut.
I do like the Berry flavor of it.
I'm gonna give it a 4 out of 10.
I don't even remember what this one was,
but I think it was a cinnamon churro one.
Again,
it tastes more like a cake.
I don't know what it is about these last three donuts.
That one was the most underwhelming one.
I get that one out of 10. First two actually really surprised me.
All in all, the maple bacon one won this little contest for me.